do you guys feel this as well i don't
know if you guys feel the same but like
for me this has been the first year
where
what i do actually feels like a career
as opposed to just me just being
self-employed doing my own [ __ ] job
that
you know i mean i've never been employed
yeah yeah yeah once all this point sorry
it just feels good it just feels like
for for the first time this isn't just
a job it's like my career now and
um i don't know just you
you you don't think doing like doing
like youtube and your job that
environment really
matters because you can do technically
do it anywhere but the more like i've
done this and the more like growing up
the more i realize
hey environment really [ __ ] matters
in in your works oh yeah like i remember
going
like i remember in university where i'm
just like i can do youtube wherever i
can do it in my
in my [ __ ] room you know i can do it
next to my bed and then i slowly realize
i need my own [ __ ] office i need my
own [ __ ] space i i
i need to separate you know work and
my leisure time because you can you can
like you can survive with it and you can
do it but
you're just there there'll end up be a
point where you get [ __ ] depressed
and you get tired
and you just it's not healthy you know
yeah
yeah i mean it definitely completely
changed my
productivity but also just like my
enthusiasm towards my
career and i guess like it really
cemented the severity
of what i do of like this isn't just
like a little fun thing that you get
paid for like this this
is this is your job right now this is
your career like
putting food on the table is this now
and everything you do
revolves around this and definitely you
know
like moving to a bigger place and
getting my own like actual work room has
like really cemented that like okay
yeah this is like yeah i can [ __ ] around
on camera and be silly and goofy
yeah but it's also my job like i can't i
can't half-ass this [ __ ] like i need to
be serious about it but like
that's brought on an entirely different
i guess
layer of enjoyment that i otherwise
would have never experienced
and i don't know like i think it's
because as well like all the topics that
we cover
of like you know the kind of otaku kind
of stuff and like anime kind of stuff
where it's like yeah doing it here
as opposed to anywhere else is just i
think completely different oh it totally
is
like one one of the biggest things i've
like realized this year is a lot of the
mystery
a lot of like the mystery and the
prestige
not the prestige like the mystery around
like the anime industry itself
has kind of like is is i see the anime
industry totally different
because i remember before like i moved
here and you know you know
as as a teenager as a kid you think
maybe maybe i could like as a dream job
i could work an anime once yeah
but like you have no [ __ ] clue what
steps you need to take
like i thought you had to be like
incredibly [ __ ] lucky and like the
more i meet people who work in this
industry
the more i realized oh you just need to
be here
yeah you know what i mean like like you
just need to be here and know one person
yeah and that's enough
and some sometimes you could [ __ ]
look up a job on craigslist
sometimes you you know you just you
you're like teaching english or
something or something and you just
happen to be in person
you just happen to stumble upon someone
who has an opportunity it's it's like
like the biggest advice i can i can give
now if you are interested in working in
the japanese anime industry it's just to
[ __ ] be here because it's like
i've been surprised at how like
sometimes even how low the bar of entry
is because it's like the bar of entry
seems to be
okay yeah university degree but that's
that's like the minimum you have to get
a visa but
aside from that it's just kind of being
here
just hanging around the right definitely
notice that and i didn't think
i just didn't think it worked that way
you know what i mean right
i i thought it was just like closed off
to all kind of foreigners and anyone
else or it took like
years and years of building yourself
yeah yeah yeah yeah and we go
you go to those anime studios and you
just meet a guy who's like i'm american
and then you are so how did you get how
did you get this job because it was like
you think you think they just had like
the craziest [ __ ] journey
craigslist yeah yeah i mean yeah most of
the time it's just yeah i was just
teaching english and then i just saw a
job posting for a random anime job and i
just
went for the interview and i'm just like
oh wait it was that easy this entire
time
did you even speak english it's
literally the mcdonald's method
like i see an ad i'll apply for a
[ __ ] why not yeah get the jump oh
okay oh okay
i got the job cool yeah i don't know i i
i guess totally agree with that in terms
of all the mystique around it it's kind
of like slowly peeling away right
right but yeah i don't know it's hard to
summarize all my feelings
about living here and working here but
yeah definitely the structure has been
added
and i don't know if that's because of
japan or because of how we've
scheduled and built our work optimized
yeah yeah i mean
having an agency here uh that works with
us and walks with anime has been
super helpful yeah um and and has helped
me feel like a lot more
like you said structured because before
this uh
yeah i was just kind of [ __ ] around i
think and i was just hoping that the
checks kept coming in
yeah i was like i'll just keep making
stuff that i really enjoy it didn't feel
real
right yeah no and i assumed that every i
assumed that every year could be my last
yeah and now i'm starting to think okay
well you know if you know as long as i
don't do
[ __ ] anything stupid
as long as none of us get cancelled yeah
you know you know you're probably going
to be around for
a little a little bit right yeah you can
normally safely assume i've got a year
left in this
yeah right like you can probably
normally plan a year or two right and
and
you know and and some people like well
you know like
damn shouldn't you be working in like a
proper career and whatnot like what is a
proper career anymore like
bro some people like still dr like 50
years old driving ubers like is that a
career
like yeah why why people got to make a
thing about it it's just your
prerogative right
like whatever makes you happy yeah if
you're getting the money and it's making
you happy you're not hurting anybody i
think that's a proper career yeah
the way i see it as well is that like if
for some reason youtube falls through
you know in a year and i got nothing
left like hey man i've got experiences
people could like kill things right
right yeah all three of us have been
smart enough to kind of establish
ourselves
in you know fields outside of youtube
yeah my plan
my plan b used to be go back to the bbc
and get like uh go back into engineering
and
stuff but now like if youtube falls
through like i have a
like i have other plan b's of like other
businesses i could possibly get involved
in and that's like
it's gave me it's given me like in in a
career that really shouldn't have
the feeling of any kind of job security
i do feel secure that yeah i do have
a specific skill set that working in
doing this has given me as opposed to
five years ago when i'm just like what
the [ __ ] can you learn doing youtube
yeah
you know what what the [ __ ] i actually
like know how to edit a video
like like like you know when you you
look back and you start doing youtube
you just think what can i
possibly put on myself what can i
possibly put on my cv
right and then now you're like if in
terms of social media entertainment and
marketing it's like it's it's a big list
yeah yeah absolutely yeah i think i
think uh
you know a lot of people think is uh and
most youtubers
as uh you know like the [ __ ] dumb
people
dumb college dropouts i mean you do see
a lot of them who are like [ __ ] i'm in
the same category as him
yeah right but i think what people
understand is that there are a lot of
companies that
wish they had people who understood
those kind of like
a lot of companies you'll see them man
they don't [ __ ] understand social
media
and you know if you know if one if we
did lose our job there is a good chance
that we could probably work in
a company and be ahead of their social
media department or help with
strategizing right consulting
anything right i mean it's like doctor
disrespect right he was an online
creator and then he went to work for
uh i think activision right or infinity
ward and he was the head of their
community relations
oh really yeah for a while oh wow before
before coming back to streaming yeah so
before he came back that's what
he left because he was a big cod
streamer i believe right right and then
he left to go and be there community
related uh community management or
something along those social media
management right something yeah
something along those lines
and then he came back right and it
speaks to even back then
that someone who had just been doing
videos online who seems very amateurish
yeah you know that knowledge that you
gain is so invaluable and companies wish
they understood that and they could hire
as many teams as they want but
right because it's so rare especially
for someone like you know disrespect to
like
reach numbers like that right it's not
something that you can like
it's not something that it's like well i
got a degree in it i studied it
therefore i'm going to get results like
that it just doesn't happen right
you learn a lot through youtube and i
think that even if you are doing it as a
hobby now
and you don't see any potential in it i
think the skills that you're learning
are really really
like useful skills i don't think you
realize useful yeah one one thing
one important skill that i had to learn
how to do is kind of
realizing what skills i thought were
useless and were actually not useless
and
it's actually thinking back to be like
oh yeah i do know how to do this thing
maybe this is
this is actually useful in some way
because it's it's like part of part of
part of making yourself look sellable as
a person to any employee is
what skills have you have you gotten
more like experience do you have
and like we we grew up in like a
generation or at least like
especially with asian parents where we
were taught hey do well in tests
get like your degree go to university
and if you don't go to university you're
a [ __ ] dropout
and yeah yeah and
like the older they grow i grew up the
more i realized yeah if you have like
certain career options
and certain like career paths that you
want to go down yes a degree is
definitely you definitely need that but
if you kind of don't know what you want
to do yet that doesn't mean that every
other skill set you gain
is invaluable right you don't need a
degree to make a
plan b in your life right yeah it's like
i never i never learned
anything about like business or
marketing in school like i didn't take
any of those like classes i never did
any of that
yeah and i learned so much about that
kind of [ __ ] just from doing youtube
yeah and that's like a really valuable
skill to have but i didn't need to go to
school for it i just had to [ __ ]
do it yeah i just had to go through it
and experience it because the way i see
it right i have an engineering degree
yeah if you put me in an engineering
workplace
i wouldn't know [ __ ] [ __ ] exactly i
don't know what's going on
maybe i you know i understand i
understand the rough concepts that make
up a lot of basic engineering and yeah
probably teach me a lot easier but you
couldn't just plop me in an office and
be like
do it yeah i would have no clue yeah at
all because you have to learn
how that that kind of utilize that skill
right right right and and without using
it practically
it's like what am i doing i've just got
good at tests like
i was [ __ ] and i constantly got
frustrated because i never felt like i
was learning engineering although i
was i was learning the concept i felt
like a lot of it was so impractical
but i mean you were learning it through
your head but not through your body yeah